and you know what man you said something  true to impress people don't even know  you know I impressed someone that I like  I can't even remember her last name  today doesn't mean no what she looks  like today she can come up to me today I  bought her a purse and I don't even know  can you recognize her and I got in today  and I paid interest on her and I  couldn't even identify who she is today  and to me I'm like man we so often this  younger generation we so much want to  impress and there's a study that shows  out we don't buy now this generation is  not buying to impress their friends  they're buying to impress their friends  on social media right that they've never  met no and I'm like we're getting into  debt to impress me on social media to  get a double like to get a heart and you  don't know me right if you get into  trouble financially I'm not paying your  bills but you got a light yeah good luck  good luck spending those legs come on  man  you